[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want we got kelly here with
us today
you would know her from bling empire and
all things that are rich and fancy and
we've got a bunch of questions for you
today oh geez i'm scared it's kind of
like a mixture of
ask the experts yes and off the record
today
is ask the rich person yeah do you i'm
not really that rich
i feel like no yes you are yes you are
you're
rich compared to us do you my first
question
do you wear the same socks twice yep i
wash in between but yeah
she washes her clothes and saves them
well i don't wash it i may wash it but
yeah the main one
there it is there it is do you lose
socks a lot do you oh yeah
like everybody just look at each other
do you think you're made stealing your
socks
oh if i was your mate i'd steal your
socks i know she probably has really
nice socks
i got you one of the things i was
thinking is if i was rich
like the um the the what is that like
the disregardable clothes
like underwear socks or whatever
i feel like i wouldn't even i would just
keep buying it you would just throw it
away oh it feels so wasteful
really that will feel really wasteful
rich asian person would say
very very true or depression-era
grandparents
you don't want you don't do it but kelly
wasn't born rich guys
when did you actually become a [ __ ]
wrench
i went through a lot of dips i mean as
an entrepreneur you always go through
dips yeah
but you know grub i grew up in china
with a pretty very comfortable lifestyle
immigrant to
us and just our first apartment was 250
a month
it was super rough and then my mom
worked her way up
and then i started working i started
working full time when i was 18. so what
did your parents do they were all
my whole family are doctors but then
when it came to the u.s my mom had to go
through residency all over again but she
had to support me
so a single mom and she was working she
was doing anti-cancer research working
two restaurants and uh wow wow yeah
she's a
she's a super she's a super woman that's
incredible
started and then started doing finance
and then you know
and then moved us to a very nice suburb
so she was
working on being a doctor she goes [ __ ]
this [ __ ] finance she can't do the
residency there's no way she was a
doctor already in china she has an md
but she has to go through residency in
order to practice yeah and you know she
couldn't do it
while raising me yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then uh and then i built my business
uh what was the first business you did i
bought a restaurant
on sunset and a when i was 23.
um sunset in hollywood how did you get
the moolah to buy the
i worked really hard um and then also i
have
really great friends that you know
believed in me and uh put money too so
kind of like crowdfunded
amongst what kind of food it was a diner
it was a trinity diner and then
upstairs of that restaurant i found out
was jim morrison's apartment from the
doors
so i um i ended up changing that into
the morrison room it was a private
lounge speakeasy it was like speakeasy
that's good
i like that you go through a dark
parking lot you got to follow the light
up lizard
and you know it was really cool we only
no pictures allowed
just before solo house so and then uh
private parties and after hours and all
that stuff that was really fun
so that's where you found your first
kind of like successful endeavor
and then you're just like i'm crushing
it i don't know if i was crushing it
i learned a lot of lessons from it you
know um
but when i sold the restaurant i started
getting the tech so i invested in
different startup companies and
put funds together for that and then
when you sold your restaurant would you
say that's your first like
big break or first big time you're like
oh i'm getting pretty successful not
really
i don't think so yeah i think restaurant
is so hard restaurants hard
thank goodness we didn't really lose
money but it was it was hard i mean
there was a month that i'm like
okay i gotta either pay the rent
tomorrow or pay the employees but then
there's also
you know great month that's like really
you know really well so there's
we've been doing really really well it
just goes up and down like crazy yeah
when we first opened we did really well
and then
west hollywood decided to remake all
their sidewalks
so we had no entries or a restaurant
because they like
were um but and then the city's not
doing anything to reimburse you for the
all the business you
you know you lose you just don't know
yeah it's it's hard every business is
hard but i learned a lot from it and
then when was the point where
you're just like oh baby
i made it and you just said oh baby to
the left or to the right is i know for
us
it was 2016 or 2015. baby
i'm gonna buy me a birthday we went from
six figures to seven
that's the point when i was like oh baby
we can pay each other now
that's pretty awesome though that's
pretty i think for me was you know when
um
okay well i had that that the the i
guess the whatever
of my lifestyle was when i was married
to my ex-husband
who i don't know you don't watch the
show so
i heard about it though because people
are at power ranger no not the power
ranger the one before the powder
he doesn't watch the show the ones
before power ranger why do you look so
sad
no no just trying to figure out which
one it is
i found out because my fans were trying
to get the dirt on you and they're like
by the way is kelly just mooching off of
her ex-husband's money or is she
actually successful on her own i was
like [ __ ]
i know her because i did business with
her in your face
but not really i don't want to call you
a [ __ ] because you're my fan i actually
i actually lost money
from the america because uh so you know
he was for me i respect him a lot back
then when i before i knew it he
he made us for the first million was 18
years old he's an immigrant as well from
china
and super like just very very smart you
know
um but later on after we were separated
already this is so even
after we're separated we separate
households everything i found out
um that's when he got served i found out
he was running on
one of the biggest cyber scams
yeah so his name satoshi that's not a
scam bro i will fight you i will
be fighting what the [ __ ] dude i will
literally fight you
and i will lose satoshi yeah so
um but you know however during a time a
lot so
he ended up having to settle for 168
million dollars but
the times that we were married the money
i always
i still was making good money the money
i made during that time
i had a it got it got lumped into it
because he didn't really have 168
million dollars in his bank account
right so everything
all the stuff i actually earned outside
of it were
lumped in it so i actually lost money is
it because when you're married
you share bank accounts and all these
things so then they can take your
assets we didn't share bank accounts but
we're legally married so what kind of
gold digger are you then oh
horrible one a horrible one god damn it
dude it's an
easy job apparently she's a gold giver
not a digger
i gotta learn from that con artist he
funded the cyber scam you know
take a class or something this is
pathetic i need to
yeah horrible so did he come from wealth
or he was just no he made everything
like he was lit he was like
sleeping on the floor when he was
growing up because his family didn't
have an extra like
bedroom for him so yeah i mean when he
telling the story without knowing that
was a you know
like a scam i was like oh my god this
guy is like you had a lot of respect for
him i still admire his hustle oh yeah
that's cool yeah yeah um for me i'm like
okay so around college is when i started
to realize that
you know a 80 000 job is a lot of money
and then wait later on a couple years
later you go that's not that much a
hundred thousand is a lot and then later
you go
wait there's people that make like half
a million dollars
and then your world just opens up and
opens up right and then you realize
oh there's a lot of people out there
that make this in a day like a hundred
thousand dollars in a day
or whatever when do you think like there
was ever a point when your world just
opened up
like out of nowhere and you're like oh
[ __ ] there's a lot of rich people in
this world
like because you you have friends like
did they when did you get these
hella rich friends i don't know i think
in my 20s i think you know i think
there's an
organic in a circle and i traveled a lot
so um
but you know they're just normal people
like you met one and but did it blow
your
because you didn't grow up rich right
because like i think all of us who are
entrepreneurs like you start slowly
meeting these hella rich people and
you're like oh my god i've been living
in a cave i didn't realize that
these people existed i don't know if i
ever had that moment because i feel like
everybody's kind of normal i treat them
like the same thing i would treat
anybody you know
like so and then just i think in the day
you as long as you develop like real
relationships and real friendships
because you know i i'm friends with them
purely because of them and vice versa
right yeah yeah so you don't
you didn't know until like all these
things happen and you're like oh [ __ ]
you're rich oh you're rich oh wait
how big is this house yeah i didn't even
notice like are you kidding me wow
well i don't even know i don't even ask
the same thing with my friends i don't
tell them what i have and you know and
i'm
normally like i'm in my sweatpants i'm
never really dressed up but you could
tell when you're hanging out like when i
was in high school
i went to this military school and
there's full a bunch of rich people
and we went back to l.a went to go eat
and we're like 16
and we go eat and then uh we thought raw
is going to have fun because we're
connecting because we're people right
i get the menu and i'm like oh shoot
what the [ __ ] i'm like are we only
trying to order the appetizers or like
what the hell is going on because
everything's like 60 bucks 80 bucks or
100 bucks
and for a high schooler that's used to
eating like five dollars at mcdonald's
i'm like oh [ __ ] and it was just crazy
to my mics and like that's
you know when you go with like an asian
parent to even an asian restaurant
something that's 20 bucks is a lot
and i'm like and this kid is like yo get
whatever the [ __ ] you guys want i'm like
oh thank god i have the favorite [ __ ]
60 bucks 80 dollars and that was just
blowing like my mind like crazy today's
video is sponsored by
upstart upstart is the fast and easy way
you can pay off all your debt all online
and it's really really super simple to
do sometimes you can even get
all your money in like one business day
yeah it comes really fast i actually
used it
um you know i'm moving and when you move
there's a ton
of different costs and one of the things
i was trying to do is build
a really sick home gym in my garage
because we don't have a barbell brigade
in vegas of course so i got my estimate
on my quote
for the home gym i'm like oh [ __ ] this
is a unforeseen cost
i had money set aside for landscaping
money set aside for interior design
crypto but i don't want to you know i do
have other investments in assets but i
don't want to liquidate them
because i think they're going to grow so
i'm like what can i do
and i'm like oh you know what upstart we
always talk about upstart all the time
so i went online and in five minutes i
got a loan because they can give you a
loan between five to fifty
our gym is pretty expensive so right in
the middle of that and i was able to get
a loan right away so that really helps
me out
because then whatever i was able to
budget that went out of budget i don't
have to wait until
way later or until i liquefy any of my
current assets i was able to get what i
wanted to do
through upstart so thank you upstart
sponsored us and you just paid them
right back
right back that's pretty awesome though
yeah yeah and so what i liked about them
too is you know they
do more than just your credit score they
look at your income your employment
history and all that stuff so
that was super cool so if you guys are
looking to see if
upstart can help lower your monthly
payments or help you in a situation like
mine
make sure you go to upstart.com off the
record
that's upstart.com off the record and
the actual loan amount will be
determined by your income
your credit score and any other
information that you put in your
loan application thank you so much
upstart dude i did i had a rich ex
and i would when we went to dinner it's
like the first couple times i'm like
getting like little tiny salads and [ __ ]
and i'm just like oh no i'm just not
that hungry you know what i'm saying i'm
[ __ ] starving
starving but then they had to like give
me the lowdown like no we want to pay
for everything i'm like dude i can't
handle that
but i wasn't used to the rich rich wrist
[ __ ] like where they literally had wings
of their house like where i'm like
wings dude yeah that's crazy so you
weren't really good like a hospital cold
digger either
[ __ ] i was horrible at it i tried to pay
for everything with with this chick
damn so we can't learn i can't learn
from you no i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry your best shot is this guy
he lives in a [ __ ] garage so
we're doomed with the tech company are
you still in the
investing in the tech company i'm not
actively but i still have like shares in
a lot of these companies
so yeah just waiting for the ipo
is that brutal waiting yeah yeah cause
some of them is like
five six seven years and couple of them
were really close and just didn't close
and you know one thing i noticed when i
was with the riches right so i'm seeing
them like this yeah i'm seeing like her
dad
like their friends and they all just
compare everything to each other brands
like watches they're into watches
they're kids colleges that was the
biggest thing
right like that's almost like the
biggest [ __ ] flash piece they could
put on the table it's like oh they got
accepted here it's a dick measuring
contest
and that's why when that um the scandal
the admission scandal happened i was
like i know who these people are
i saw that pressure up close and
personal they cost like a million
dollars for like harvard or like these
ivy league schools
that's a lot it's a whole business like
getting them into the schools and it's
been going after you watch the
documentary yeah it's on netflix
pretty interesting but that's just been
going on for like decades
yeah i saw the one on youtube is it a
different one or was it just a
free it was probably personal person
somebody made it fan made
yeah it was independent guy voicing over
some stuff
some stock footage stock footage yeah
but do you notice that like with the
competition like as far as what would
you say is the top echelon
brands cars houses kids education
all of it you know but again there's
only i try not
to at least associate myself too much
into that because for me i i don't
it's it's whatever you can't take that
[ __ ] with you when you pass away that's
true
yeah that's what i've noticed too is
like i gravitate more toward like so we
have a mutual friend who's
also an entrepreneur very like
successful but um
he's the most down-to-earth person like
you would ever meet and you would never
know that he has eight figures to his
name
like he's just he's just happy to do
like he'll mop the floor he'll do
everything he just loves to work
the funny thing is that when i met him
for a whole year i had no idea what we
did
really yeah we were you know just
playing yeah yeah he's a foodie we'll go
eat
and hang out and then after like a year
year and a half later i'm like what do
you
do it's like he's always working but you
just don't know if any of these things
actually work
you know and but yeah he's amazing yeah
what does he do
yeah yeah for [ __ ] sake he uh him and
his brother
started this video game uh distribution
company
and they invented a lot of things like
the console that
has all the games in one they have the
only license for nintendo console remake
it's the largest toy in gaming
distribution in north america
i've seen those little super nintendos
and [ __ ] yeah but he is the distributor
wholesaler and he has partnership in
in china for the factory wow but he's
not the retailer so like
yeah people don't know that all those
games and whatever just go back to him
and his brother dude i met a guy
all he did not even kidding he's one of
the richest people i've ever met in my
life
he's like yeah roller coaster wheels and
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
it's a non-sexy thing that's like don't
even know it exists
you don't even think about roller
coaster wheels he's like yeah dude i
[ __ ] just sell roller coaster wheels
straight up and i'm like that's it
he's like yeah man you know how like
you're on a roller coaster i'm like no i
get it
but that's it there's a whole market for
that
like what right like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about man true it's always
something really small like
you kind of invent something and pattern
it that's it i met somebody that was so
rich
he was from singapore all he did was
like
he just was he was the middleman for
logistics for shipping poinsettias
from from out of overseas to the us
yeah the the plan you're the during
christmas time the red one
wow i've also kicked it with two
billionaires
wow okay they're the cheapest [ __ ]
people i've ever made in my life
that's why they're billionaires they're
the cheapest [ __ ] people i've ever
met in my life i had one movie deal
go fall through i don't care if you
figure this out and you know who you are
i had one movie deal we were this close
to being just [ __ ] it was like
everything's about to get
get greenlit it falls through at the
very bitter end
because they're afraid we can't meet our
budget which we've met our budget for
every movie we've made so far
so and we've been under budget for a
couple of them so i'm like no
we'll do it we can do it but this cat
was just like i don't see how they could
possibly pull that off does he sound
like that
maybe
[Laughter]
but no it's just it's so funny how like
you're literally a billionaire everyone
knows you're a billionaire you call
yourself a billionaire and then at the
end of the day like
this might be too much he's like 20
000 a little too much no kidding maybe
that's how they became
you know of course because they're just
they don't
stop understanding the value of the
dollar yeah whereas like
the most of us we make more we spend
more that's also kind of stressful
i feel like i want to have more money so
i could think less about it
yeah you know like that that's that
would be like my motivation or my reason
it's funny to make fun of like the rich
but also we know that it's
a diverse group of people like you have
your hell of down to earth people like
they
just because someone makes a lot of
money doesn't mean that it all of a
sudden groups them into one personality
type that's true like they
you know it's a common phrase of like
rich and greedy like rich and [ __ ] up
rich and like heartless or whatever like
there's like
this evilness that comes along with
wealth but then we all know
personally a lot of wealthy people that
are really [ __ ] awesome people
so name one our buddy joy
nice i like that joey i've known joy for
eight years it's been my mission to make
him mad
he's impossible impossible yeah he's
just happy all the time
no that's why i did not but he's a
foodie i even like hit his lunch
like you know starve him and you know
hangry you know yeah yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
it doesn't work he's always just
i just i just hit it but yeah wow he's
always happy
she couldn't do it he's the most
grateful like for life dude i've ever
met
and we used to go raving and partying
and doing like a lot of drugs and he
just disappeared he's been like that
since the
raving yes that's always been like jolly
ass dude like and then um
his family owned like a donut shop
because they're like cambodian and you
know how they all like own donut shops
his uncle is the king of donuts yeah the
king of donut yeah so we called him
donut joey and then like we would go
visit him and he would like
give us some donuts and he's like we're
gonna go rave later and then
later on we're like [ __ ] doing the
candy walk we're all like high on each
are you supposed to tell this
what's the candy walk oh it was this
dance that we go like this on
he's the old school rave dance can you
do it
it's the door the track oh my days are
over man i'm retired
he's not on east yeah yeah it wouldn't
be right no but they're like the running
man
no but but the thing is all of that i
mean that we were like what 14 back then
right so he you know he's not about that
now obviously
but then he disappeared and then i just
hear this like
fable of like oh yeah he's like a
millionaire now he has an ebay business
and this and that and i'm like what
it inspired me to actually do my ebay
business because i thought wow he could
do it and then later
we we catch up and then he just this
video game mogul
and i'm like what the [ __ ] but he hasn't
changed he's still that jolly happy
positive dude and he's been through a
lot too
yeah he had to rescue his family from
like he said they were going bankrupt
and the way that they found out was the
repo man coming in and taking out
all the stuff from their house so him
and his brother had a
in their teens they had to take over and
help the family pay bills and they had
to they had to be an adult like at 17
so that's like that's why you weren't
raving with me anymore
lame i had a repo man come from my truck
because i had unpaid parking tickets all
kinds of [ __ ]
and in la they compound yeah and so
eventually i was so
utterly [ __ ] yeah that a repo man
shows up but i i had moved to la
and my address was still san diego so
the repo man knocks on my dad's door
and my dad and they're like hey dude
we're looking for this truck and my
dad's like
i don't know who that is i've never
heard of that in my whole life what a
jeep
how tight is that yeah you're like my
dad's got my back i know
ain't no snitch i never knew that about
my dad either but
i guess my dad's white trash enough to
know the rules that's ty
he's like i ain't no snitch man yeah
that was cool wow
my mom will be like here's her social
security number her address everything
for her birthday
go get her don't take me to jail just
don't take me to jail
[Music]
you